wir sehen hier dieses bekenner foto
vielleicht können wir da noch einmal
drauf schauen dieses bekennt sich im
nachrichten ins telegramm zu diesem
anschlag werden ihnen gerade darüber
gesprochen dass das überhaupt nicht geht
ohne die taliban die jetzt wiederum vom
us militär um hilfe gebeten werden um
der situation dort überhaupt herr zu
werden
ist das überhaupt möglich wie soll das
gehen höre ich habe wirklich keine wort
20 jahre ein targa nie sation bekämpfen
um letztendlich ihn um hilfe zu bitten
weil jetzt eine andere tiroler version
die noch schlimmer irgendwie terror
taliban ist eine faschistische terror
organisation man kann versuchen sie
moderat zu halten man kann versuchen mit
denen zu reden vielleicht muss man auch
mit der reden letztendlich werden sie
sich nicht verändern sie werden frauen
unterdrücken sie werden terror
strukturen aufbauen und sie werden das
tun was sie vor 21 jahren getan haben
sie werden vielleicht eine instagram
bilder schaffen wo sie demokratie
irgendwie
strahlen aber sie bleiben eine
faschistische organisation und noch ein
hinweis genau solche bilder von
terroristen die gerade terroranschläge
verüben diese siegel
siegerbilder die wir sehen werden leider
nächsten tagen werden islamisten überall
in der welt dazu bewegen sich nach
afghanistan auf dem weg zu machen um da
eine islamische staat sich zu zu
anzuschließen genau was wir in syrien
gesehen haben und damals mit al qaida
und es werden auch europäer die diesem
ruf folgen und da hingehen ausbildung
haben und von daten überall in der welt
explodieren das ist fatal dass es
wirklich fatal das vitra da erleben dass
das historische versagen den und das
wird uns in den nächsten jahren massiv
begleiten was erwarten sie da ganz
konkret auch für deutschland sie sagen
die erstarken jetzt all diese gruppen
werden sich jetzt formieren werden sich
in afghanistan treffen werden dadurch
stärker weil sie sehen wie schwach der
westen ist wie wenig reagiert wurde wie
spät reagiert wurde wie das land sich
selbst und den terroristen überlassen
wurde sie lachen uns aus und zwar nicht
nur deutschland sondern im ganzen westen
wir haben keine strategie
sind naiv ahnungslos wir haben leider
ganz deutlich und sichtbar gezeigt wir
haben zwar sagt das ist nicht der westen
das ist nicht die usa sondern man kann
auch mit bart tausende von terroristen
ein weltmacht bewegen und das wird alle
andere terrororganisationen ganz großer
motivation geben das genau zu versuchen
wir haben es übrigens erlebt auch im
nahen osten
da kommt ein hisbollah im libanon und
zielt erfolge gegen israel und bei jahre
später folgen die hamas und andere
organisationen tun das gleiche
diese islamistische idee diese
islamistische strukturen diese
politischer islam der gerade große wege
und große bilder überall zeigt wert an
fahrt gewinnen und zwar nicht nur in
afghanistan sondern überall und auch in
europa die gefahr von islamistischen
strukturen die wir erfolgreich in syrien
bekämpft haben es wieder da und wird uns
in den nächsten jahren beschäftigen
[Musik]